الخروج لتظاهرات طبعا في تل ابيب وذلك ضد
قرار نتنياهو فيما يتعلق بالتعديلات
وقراره الاخير ربما يمكن لنا ان نتابع بعض
الصور الان المباشره التي تاتينا من تل
ابيب كان هناك طبعا تراجع من قبل نتنياهو
بعد تظاهرات
مضاده ضد التعديلات الان هناك تظاهرات ضد
تعليق نتنياهو للاصلاحات اي الذين كانوا
داعمين طبعا هم في معظمهم كان سمعنا من
ردود الفعل كان هناك امتعاد من قرار
نتنياهو ولكن التظاهرات التي خرجت في
اسرائيل في تلك الفتره المعارضه للتعديلات
القضائيه التي كان يريد نتنياهو حكومته
طرحها قد دفعته لتغيير القرار والاعلان عن
فتح الحوار والمفاوضات مع المعارضه التي
اصرت بانها لن تخرج من الشارع قبل وقف هذه
التعديلات طبعا لا نعلم حتى الان اذا كان
الوقت سيكون نهائي ولكن من المفترض انه
بحسب التصريحات فانه مجمد وذلك لتهدئه
الاوضاع البعض كان قد علق بان نتنياهو
اتخذ القرار لتهدئه الشارع